تتعدد اسباب الانجازات التي تمنح للموظفين
لظروف مختلفه وعلى غرار اجازه الزواج
ستمنح شركات كبرى في بريطانيا في جزر
الطلاق لكنها غير محسوبه من رصيد الموظف
حيث اعربت شركتك كبرى في بريطانيا وانضم
اليها اكبر قضاه ومحام والاسره في البلاد
عن دعم برنامج يمنح الاباء اجازه عمل
عندنا الانفصال قسم الموارد البشريه في
هذه الشركات سيعدل قوانينها بلا ان على
اعتبار الانفصال حدث مشابها لحالات الوفاه
العائليه او الاصابه بمرض عضال وستوفر تلك
المؤسسات للموظفين اجازات او ساعات عمل
مارينا كي يتمكنوا من الوفاء بالالتزامات
السحاب الاطفال الى المدرسه بل ستسهل
وصولهم الى مكاتب خدمه الدعم والاستشارات
هذا التعديل تم بناء على دراسه حول اثر
انفصال على الموظفين التابع العالم
في البرلمان البريطاني تم الكشف عن برنامج
طرحه تحالف القوه الايجابيه حسب نشرته
صحيفه التايمز والذي قام باستطلاع حول اثر
الطلاق او الانفصال على الاداء في العمل
وفي الاستطلاع قال 90% من الموظفين ان
عملهم تاثر سلبا بطلاقهم بينما قال 95%
منهم ان صحتهم العقليه في العمل
متضررات كذلك واعترف نحو 75% منهم بانهم
اصبحوا اقل كفاءه في العمل بينما اوضح 40%
انهم اخذوا اجازات عمل نتيجه انفصالهم
وذكر 52% منهم انهم شعره بالخوف من فقدان
وظائفهم يتفكروا في الاستقاله بينما توقف
12% منهم بالفعل عن العمل تماما
[موسيقى]
نحن على كل حال سالنا الناس انطلاقا
محاوله التبني فكره منح الموظفين اجازات
الطلاق
ما هي الاجازات الاخرى التي يحتاج اليها
الموظف وغير متاحه
ما في حاله معينه اللي او مناسبه نعطي
عليها اجازه المفروض المدراء يصيروا
يفكروا الطريقه يتفهموا الموظفين اكثر
يعرفوا متى لازم ينعت الموظف اجازه يعني
خلينا نقول الموظف لازم يحتاج من فتره
للفتره اللي راح على طلعه يغير جو يعمل
استجمام عشان يستجمع قوه يقدر ينجز اكثر
فبيكون ادائه افضل هذه الاجازات منسيه
عندنا احنا يعني حدا من الفريق عنده
امتحان حدا عنده ظرف عائلي احد عنده كذا
انا بصراحه ما بوثق باعتمد على التعامل
الانساني بشكل موظف يعني انجازات متاحه له
يعني له سنه 14 يوم اكثر من هيك حرام يعني
ضغط الشغل لازم يكون في اجازات يعني انه
الواحد يقدر يروح يريح شوي ويرجع يتابع
شغله يعني هلا بعطوه اجازات للزواج
يومين ثلاثه من الطلاق
والله فكره حلوه
الموظف بيكون تعبان نفسيا مضغوط
ممكن احتاج هذه القزازه ممكن مقدرش يشرح
ايش تعبان هو
بحاجه يكون يعطل عن شغله
يعني على كل حال مثل هكذا برامج هي ليست
موجوده في بريطانيا فقط ايضا كمان في
الولايات المتحده الامريكيه الحاله
الاجتماعيه ومحصنه هناك في قانون العمل
على كل حال
الموظف بانه يتعرض بسبب حالات الاجتماعيه
سواء اعزب او متزوج وحتى مطلق يحق له
نقابات الشركه اذا اثبت ذلك اه يعني ليس
فقط اذا كان مطلق ايضا اذا كان متزوج يعني
كمان هذه الفكره هذا ينصح خبراء الموارد
البشريه بالتعامل مع الاداء الضعيف للموظف
المنفصل بحرص خاصه اذا استمر طويله لكن
هناك قضيه شهيره غريبه يا نادين
الزواج والطلاق لعده همم كي يستفيد من هذه
الاجازه المدفوعه التي يمنحها قانون العمل
لمده ايام يعني تخيل انه الاغرب من هيك
انه تم فرد غرامي على المسرح اللي بيعمل
فيه يعني كل شويه قرض زواج بعدين طلاق ههه
ههه واحاول قوانين الاجازات ايضا كوريا
الجنوبيه تعتزم منح فتره اجازه للاباء تصل
الى عام وسته اشهر بدلا من الاجازه
الحاليه وهي عام بعد الولاده على كل حال
يرجح سبب انخفاض الكبير اللي بتشهده في
عدد المواليد ضغوطات الحياه هيك بخدمها
يعني طبعا يعني تقريبا
لا سمح الله يتجه نحو اجازات الطلاق
واجازات الابوه يعني ما فيش حل وسط